The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
start now with a new chapter.
We're going to talk about
Markov processes.
The good news is that this is
a subject that is a lot more
intuitive and simple in many
ways than, let's say, the
Poisson processes.
So hopefully this will
be enjoyable.
So Markov processes
is, a general
class of random processes.
In some sense, it's more
elaborate than the Bernoulli
and Poisson processes, because
now we're going to have
dependencies between difference
times, instead of
having memoryless processes.
So the basic idea is
the following.
In physics, for example, you
write down equations for how a
system evolves that has
the general form.
The new state of a system one
second later is some function
of old state.
So Newton's equations and all
that in physics allow you to
write equations of this kind.
And so if that a particle is
moving at a certain velocity
and it's at some location, you
can predict when it's going to
be a little later.
Markov processes have the same
flavor, except that there's
also some randomness thrown
inside the equation.
So that's what Markov process
essentially is.
It describes the evolution of
the system, or some variables,
but in the presence of some
noise so that the motion
itself is a bit random.
So this is a pretty
general framework.
So pretty much any useful or
interesting random process
that you can think about, you
can always described it as a
Markov process if you
define properly the
notion of the state.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to introduce the
class of Markov processes by,
example, by talking about the
checkout counter in
a supermarket.
Then we're going to abstract
from our example so that we
get a more general definition.
And then we're going to do a
few things, such as how to
predict what's going to happen
n time steps later, if we
start at the particular state.
And then talk a little bit
about some structural
properties of Markov processes
or Markov chains.
So here's our example.
You go to the checkout counter
at the supermarket, and you
stand there and watch the
customers who come.
So customers come, they get in
queue, and customers get
served one at a time.
So the discussion is going to
be in terms of supermarket
checkout counters, but the
same story applies to any
service system.
You may have a server, jobs
arrive to that server, they
get put into the queue, and
the server processes those
jobs one at a time.
Now to make a probabilistic
model, we need to make some
assumption about the customer
arrivals and the customer
departures.
And we want to keep things
as simple as
possible to get started.
So let's assume that customers
arrive according to a
Bernoulli process with
some parameter b.
So essentially, that's the same
as the assumption that
the time between consecutive
customer arrivals is a
geometric random variable
with parameter b.
Another way of thinking about
the arrival process--
that's not how it happens, but
it's helpful, mathematically,
is to think of someone who's
flipping a coin with bias
equal to b.
And whenever the coin
lands heads,
then a customer arrives.
So it's as if there's a coin
flip being done by nature that
decides the arrivals
of the customers.
So we know that coin flipping
to determine the customer
arrivals is the same as having
geometric inter-arrival times.
We know that from our study
of the Bernoulli process.
OK.
And now how about the customer
service times.
We're going to assume that--
OK.
If there is no customer in
queue, no one being served,
then of course, no
one is going to
depart from the queue.
But if there a customer in
queue, then that customer
starts being served, and is
going to be served for a
random amount of time.
And we make the assumption that
the time it takes for the
clerk to serve the customer has
a geometric distribution
with some known parameter q.
So the time it takes to serve a
customer is random, because
it's random how many items they
got in their cart, and
how many coupons they have
to unload and so on.
So it's random.
In the real world, it has some
probability distribution.
Let's not care exactly about
what it would be in the real
world, but as a modeling
approximation or just to get
started, let's pretend that
customer service time are well
described by a geometric
distribution,
with a parameter q.
An equivalent way of thinking
about the customer service,
mathematically, would
be, again, in
terms of coin flipping.
That is, the clerk has a coin
with a bias, and at each time
slot the clerk flips the coin.
With probability q,
service is over.
With probability 1-q, you
continue the service process.
An assumption that we're going
to make is that the coin flips
that happen here to determine
the arrivals, they're all
independent of each other.
The coin flips that determine
the end of service are also
independent from each other.
But also the coin flips involved
here are independent
from the coin flips that
happened there.
So how arrivals happen is
independent with what happens
at the service process.
OK.
So suppose now you
want to answer a
question such as the following.
The time is 7:00 PM.
What's the probability that the
customer will be departing
at this particular time?
Well, you say, it depends.
If the queue is empty at that
time, then you're certain that
you're not going to have
a customer departure.
But if the queue is not empty,
then there is probability q
that a departure will
happen at that time.
So the answer to a question like
this has something to do
with the state of the
system at that time.
It depends what the queue is.
And if I ask you, will the
queue be empty at 7:10?
Well, the answer to that
question depends on whether at
7 o'clock whether the queue
was huge or not.
So knowing something about the
state of the queue right now
gives me relevant information
about what may
happen in the future.
So what is the state
of the system?
Therefore we're brought to
start using this term.
So the state basically
corresponds to
anything that's relevant.
Anything that's happening
right now that's kind of
relevant to what may happen
in the future.
Knowing the size of the queue
right now, is useful
information for me to make
predictions about what may
happen 2 minutes
later from now.
So in this particular example,
a reasonable choice for the
state is to just count
how many customers
we have in the queue.
And let's assume that our
supermarket building is not
too big, so it can only
hold 10 people.
So we're going to limit
the states.
Instead of going from 0 to
infinity, we're going to
truncate our model at ten.
So we have 11 possible states,
corresponding to 0 customers
in queue, 1 customer in queue,
2 customers, and so on, all
the way up to 10.
So these are the different
possible states of the system,
assuming that the store cannot
handle more than 10 customers.
So this is the first step, to
write down the set of possible
states for our system.
Then the next thing to do is
to start describing the
possible transitions
between the states.
At any given time step,
what are the
things that can happen?
We can have a customer
arrival, which
moves the state 1 higher.
We can have a customer
departure, which moves the
state 1 lower.
There's a possibility that
nothing happens, in which case
the state stays the same.
And there's also the possibility
of having
simultaneously an arrival and a
departure, in which case the
state again stays the same.
So let's write some
representative probabilities.
If we have 2 customers, the
probability that during this
step we go down, this is the
probability that we have a
service completion, but to
no customer arrival.
So this is the probability
associated with this
transition.
The other possibility is that
there's a customer arrival,
which happens with probability
p, and we do not have a
customer departure, and so the
probability of that particular
transition is this number.
And then finally, the
probability that we stay in
the same state, this can happen
in 2 possible ways.
One way is that we have an
arrival and a departure
simultaneously.
And the other possibility is
that we have no arrival and no
departure, so that the
state stays the same.
So these transition
probabilities would be the
same starting from any other
states, state 3, or
state 9, and so on.
Transition probabilities become
a little different at
the borders, at the boundaries
of this diagram, because if
you're in a state 0, then you
cannot have any customer
departures.
There's no one to be served, but
there is a probability p
that the customer arrives, in
which case the number of
customers in the system
goes to 1.
Then probability 1-p,
nothing happens.
Similarly with departures, if
the system is full, there's no
room for another arrival.
But we may have a departure that
happens with probability
q, and nothing happens
with probability 1-q.
So this is the full transition
diagram annotated with
transition probabilities.
And this is a complete
description of a discrete
time, finite state
Markov chain.
So this is a complete
probabilistic model.
Once you have all of these
pieces of information, you can
start calculating things, and
trying to predict what's going
to happen in the future.
Now let us abstract from this
example and come up with a
more general definition.
So we have this concept of the
state which describes the
current situation in the system
that we're looking at.
The current state is random, so
we're going to think of it
as a random variable Xn is the
state, and transitions after
the system started operating.
So the system starts operating
at some initial state X0, and
after n transitions, it
moves to state Xn.
Now we have a set of
possible states.
State 1 state 2, state
3, and in general,
state i and state j.
To keep things simple, we
assume that the set of
possible states is
a finite set.
As you can imagine, we can
have systems in which the
state space is going
to be infinite.
It could be discrete,
or continuous.
But all that is more difficult
and more complicated.
It makes sense to start from the
simplest possible setting
where we just deal with the
finite state space.
And time is discrete, so we can
think of this state in the
beginning, after 1 transition,
2 transitions, and so on.
So we're in discrete time and we
have finite in many states.
So the system starts somewhere,
and at every time
step, the state is,
let's say, here.
A whistle blows, and the state
jumps to a random next state.
So it may move here, or it may
move there, or it may move
here, or it might stay
in the place.
So one possible transition is
the transition before you
jump, and just land
in the same place
where you started from.
Now we want to describe the
statistics of these
transitions.
If I am at that state, how
likely is it to that, next
time, I'm going to find
myself at that state?
Well, we describe the statistics
of this transition
by writing down a transition
probability, the transition
probability of going from
state 3 to state 1.
So this transition probability
is to be thought of as a
conditional probability.
Given that right now I am
at state i what is the
probability that next time
I find myself at state j?
So given that right now I am
at state 3, P31 is the
probability that the next
time I'm going to find
myself at state 1.
Similarly here, we would have
a probability P3i, which is
the probability that given that
right now I'm at state 3,
next time I'm going to find
myself at state i.
Now one can write such
conditional probabilities down
in principle, but we
need to make--
so you might think of this as a
definition here, but we need
to make one additional big
assumption, and this is the
assumption that to
make a process
to be a Markov process.
This is the so-called
Markov property, and
here's what it says.
Let me describe it first
in words here.
Every time that I find myself
at state 3, the probability
that next time I'm going to find
myself at state 1 is this
particular number, no matter
how I got there.
That is, this transition
probability is not affected by
the past of the process.
It doesn't care about what
path I used to find
myself at state 3.
Mathematically, it means
the following.
You have this transition
probability that from state i
jump to state j.
Suppose that I gave you some
additional information, that I
told you everything else that
happened in the past of the
process, everything that
happened, how did you
get to state i?
The assumption we're making is
that this information about
the past has no bearing in
making predictions about the
future, as long as you know
where you are right now.
So if I tell you, right now, you
are at state i, and by the
way, you got there by following
a particular path,
you can ignore the extra
information of the particular
path that you followed.
You only take into account
where you are right now.
So every time you find yourself
at that state, no
matter how you got there, you
will find yourself next time
at state 1 with probability
P31.
So the past has no bearing into
the future, as long as
you know where you are
sitting right now.
For this property to happen, you
need to choose your state
carefully in the right way.
In that sense, the states
needs to include any
information that's relevant
about the
future of the system.
Anything that's not in the state
is not going to play a
role, but the state needs to
have all the information
that's relevant in determining
what kind of transitions are
going to happen next.
So to take an example, before
you go to Markov process, just
from the deterministic world,
if you have a ball that's
flying up in the air, and you
want to make predictions about
the future.
If I tell you that the state of
the ball is the position of
the ball at the particular time,
is that enough for you
to make predictions where the
ball is going to go next?
No.
You need to know both the
position and the velocity.
If you know position and
velocity, you can make
predictions about the future.
So the state of a ball that's
flying is position together
with velocity.
If you were to just take
position, that would not be
enough information, because if
I tell you current position,
and then I tell you past
position, you could use the
information from the past
position to complete the
trajectory and to make
the prediction.
So information from the past
is useful if you don't know
the velocity.
But if both position and
velocity, you don't care how
you got there, or what
time you started.
From position and velocity, you
can make predictions about
the future.
So there's a certain art, or a
certain element of thinking, a
non-mechanical aspect into
problems of this kind, to
figure out which is the
right state variable.
When you define the state of
your system, you need to
define it in such a way that
includes all information that
has been accumulated that has
some relevance for the future.
So the general process for
coming up with a Markov model
is to first make this big
decision of what your state
variable is going to be.
Then you write down if it
may be a picture of
the different states.
Then you identify the possible
transitions.
So sometimes the diagram that
you're going to have will not
include all the possible arcs.
You would only show those arcs
that correspond to transitions
that are possible.
For example, in the supermarket
example, we did
not have a transition from state
2 to state 5, because
that cannot happen.
You can only have 1 arrival
at any time.
So in the diagram, we only
showed the possible
transitions.
And for each of the possible
transitions, then you work
with the description of the
model to figure out the
correct transition
probability.
So you got the diagram by
writing down transition
probabilities.
OK, so suppose you got
your Markov model.
What will you do with it?
Well, what do we need
models for?
We need models in order to
make predictions, to make
probabilistic predictions.
So for example, I tell you that
the process started in
that state.
You let it run for some time.
Where do you think it's going to
be 10 time steps from now?
That's a question that you
might want to answer.
Since the process is random,
there's no way for you to tell
me exactly where it's
going to be.
But maybe you can give
me probabilities.
You can tell me, with so
much probability, the
state would be there.
With so much probability,
the state would be
there, and so on.
So our first exercise is to
calculate those probabilities
about what may happen to the
process a number of steps in
the future.
It's handy to have some
notation in here.
So somebody tells us that this
process starts at the
particular state i.
We let the process run
for n transitions.
It may land at some state j, but
that state j at which it's
going to land is going
to be random.
So we want to give
probabilities.
Tell me, with what probability
the state, n times steps
later, is going to be that
particular state j?
The shorthand notation is to use
this symbol here for the
n-step transition probabilities
that you find
yourself at state j given that
you started at state i.
So the way these two indices are
ordered, the way to think
about them is that from
i, you go to j.
So the probability that from
i you go to j if you have n
steps in front of you.
Some of these transition
probabilities are, of course
easy to write.
For example, in 0 transitions,
you're going to be exactly
where you started.
So this probability is going to
be equal to 1 if i is equal
to j, And 0 if i is
different than j.
That's an easy one
to write down.
If you have only 1 transition,
what's the probability that 1
step later you find yourself
in state j given that you
started at state i?
What is this?
These are just the ordinary
1-step transition
probabilities that we are given
in the description of
the problem.
So by definition, the 1-step
transition probabilities are
of this form.
This equality is correct just
because of the way that we
defined those two quantities.
Now we want to say something
about the n-step transition
probabilities when n
is a bigger number.
OK.
So here, we're going to use the
total probability theorem.
So we're going to condition in
two different scenarios, and
break up the calculation of this
quantity, by considering
the different ways that
this event can happen.
So what is the event
of interest?
The event of interest
is the following.
At time 0 we start i.
We are interested in landing
at time n at the
particular state j.
Now this event can happen in
several different ways, in
lots of different ways.
But let us group them
into subgroups.
One group, or one sort of
scenario, is the following.
During the first n-1 time steps,
things happen, and
somehow you end up at state 1.
And then from state 1, in the
next time step you make a
transition to state j.
This particular arc here
actually corresponds to lots
and lots of different possible
scenarios, or different spots,
or different transitions.
In n-1 time steps, there's lots
of possible ways by which
you could end up at state 1.
Different paths through
the state space.
But all of them together
collectively have a
probability, which is the
(n-1)-step transition
probability, that from state
i, you end up at state 1
And then there's other
possible scenarios.
Perhaps in the first n-1 time
steps, you follow the
trajectory that took
you at state m.
And then from state m, you did
this transition, and you ended
up at state j.
So this diagram breaks up
the set of all possible
trajectories from i to j into
different collections, where
each collection has to do with
which one happens to be the
state just before the last time
step, just before time n.
And we're going to condition
on the state at time n-1.
So the total probability of
ending up at state j is the
sum of the probabilities of
the different scenarios --
the different ways that you
can get to state j.
If we look at that type of
scenario, what's the
probability of that scenario
happening?
With probability Ri1(n-1),
I find myself at
state 1 at time n-1.
This is just by the definition
of these multi-step transition
probabilities.
This is the number
of transitions.
The probability that from state
i, I end up at state 1.
And then given that I found
myself at state 1, with
probability P1j, that's the
transition probability, next
time I'm going to find
myself at state j.
So the product of these two is
the total probability of my
getting from state i to
state j through state
1 at the time before.
Now where exactly did we use
the Markov assumption here?
No matter which particular path
we used to get from i to
state 1, the probability that
next I'm going to make this
transition is that
same number, P1j.
So that number does not depend
on the particular path that I
followed in order
to get there.
If we didn't have the Markov
assumption, we should have
considered all possible
individual trajectories here,
and then we would need to use
the transition probability
that corresponds to that
particular trajectory.
But because of the Markov
assumption, the only thing
that matters is that right
now we are at state 1.
It does not matter
how we got there.
So now once you see this
scenario, then this scenario,
and that scenario, and you add
the probabilities of these
different scenarios, you end
up with this formula here,
which is a recursion.
It tells us that once you have
computed the (n-1)-step
transition probabilities, then
you can compute also the
n-step transition
probabilities.
This is a recursion that you
execute or you run for all i's
and j's simultaneously.
That is fixed.
And for a particular n, you
calculate this quantity for
all possible i's, j's, k's.
You have all of those
quantities, and then you use
this equation to find those
numbers again for all the
possible i's and j's.
Now this is formula which is
always true, and there's a big
idea behind the formula.
And now there's variations of
this formula, depending on
whether you're interested
in something
that's slightly different.
So for example, if you were to
have a random initial state,
somebody gives you the
probability distribution of
the initial state, so you're
told that with probability
such and such, you're going
to start at state 1.
With that probability, you're
going to start at
state 2, and so on.
And you want to find the
probability at the time n you
find yourself at state j.
Well again, total probability
theorem, you condition on the
initial state.
With this probability you find
yourself at that particular
initial state, and given that
this is your initial state,
this is the probability that
n time steps later you find
yourself at state j.
Now building again on the same
idea, you can run every
recursion of this kind
by conditioning
at different times.
So here's a variation.
You start at state i.
After 1 time step, you find
yourself at state 1, with
probability pi1, and you find
yourself at state m with
probability Pim.
And once that happens, then
you're going to follow some
trajectories.
And there is a possibility that
you're going to end up at
state j after n-1 time steps.
This scenario can happen
in many possible ways.
There's lots of possible paths
from state 1 to state j.
There's many paths from
state 1 to state j.
What is the collective
probability of all these
transitions?
This is the event that, starting
from state 1, I end
up at state j in
n-1 time steps.
So this one has here probability
R1j of n-1.
And similarly down here.
And then by using the same way
of thinking as before, we get
the formula that Rij(n) is the
sum over all k's of Pik, and
then the Rkj(n-1).
So this formula looks almost the
same as this one, but it's
actually different.
The indices and the way things
work out are a bit different,
but the basic idea
is the same.
Here we use the total
probability theory by
conditioning on the state just
1 step before the end of our
time horizon.
Here we use total probability
theorem by conditioning on the
state right after the
first transition.
So this generally idea has
different variations.
They're all valid, and depending
on the context that
you're dealing with, you might
want to work with one of these
or another.
So let's illustrate
these calculations
in terms of an example.
So in this example, we just have
2 states, and somebody
gives us transition
probabilities to be those
particular numbers.
Let's write down
the equations.
So the probability that starting
from state 1, I find
myself at state 1 n
time steps later.
This can happen in 2 ways.
At time n-1, I might find
myself at state 2.
And then from state 2, I make a
transition back to state 1,
which happens with
probability--
why'd I put 2 there --
anyway, 0.2.
And another way is that from
state 1, I go to state 1 in
n-1 steps, and then from state
1 I stay where I am, which
happens with probability 0.5.
So this is for R11(n).
Now R12(n), we can
write a similar
recursion for this one.
On the other hand, seems these
are probabilities.
The state at time n is
going to be either
state 1 or state 2.
So these 2 numbers need to add
to 1, so we can just write
this as 1 - R11(n).
And this is an enough of a
recursion to propagate R11 and
R12 as time goes on.
So after n-1 transitions, either
I find myself in state
2, and then there's a point to
transition that I go to 1, or
I find myself in state 1, which
with that probability,
and from there, I have
probability 0.5 of staying
where I am.
Now let's start calculating.
As we discussed before, if I
start at state 1, after 0
transitions I'm certain to be at
state , and I'm certain not
to be at state 1.
If I start from state 1, I'm
certain to not to be at state
at that time, and I'm certain
that I am right
now, it's state 1.
After I make transition,
starting from state 1, there's
probability 0.5 that
I stay at state 1.
And there's probability 0.5
that I stay at state 2.
If I were to start from state
2, the probability that I go
to 1 in 1 time step is this
transition that has
probability 0.2, and
the other 0.8.
OK.
So the calculation now becomes
more interesting, if we want
to calculate the next term.
How likely is that at time 2,
I find myself at state 1?
In order to be here at state 1,
this can happen in 2 ways.
Either the first transition left
me there, and the second
transition is the same.
So these correspond to this 0.5,
that the first transition
took me there, and the
next transition was
also of the same kind.
That's one possibility.
But there's another scenario.
In order to be at state 1
at time 2 -- this can
also happen this way.
So that's the event
that, after 1
transition, I got there.
And the next transition happened
to be this one.
So this corresponds
to 0.5 times 0.2.
It corresponds to taking the
1-step transition probability
of getting there, times the
probability that from state 2
I move to state 1, which
in this case, is 0.2.
So basically we take this
number, multiplied with 0.2,
and then add those 2 numbers.
And after you add them,
you get 0.35.
And similarly here, you're
going to get 0.65.
And now to continue with the
recursion, we keep doing the
same thing.
We take this number times 0.5
plus this number times 0.2.
Add them up, you get
the next entry.
Keep doing that, keep doing
that, and eventually you will
notice that the numbers
start settling into a
limiting value at 2/7.
And let's verify this.
If this number is 2/7, what is
the next number going to be?
The next number is going to
be 2/7 -- (not 2.7) --
it's going to be 2/7.
That's the probability that I
find myself at that state,
times 0.5--
that's the next transition that
takes me to state 1 --
plus 5/7--
that would be the remaining
probability that I find myself
in state 2 --
times 1/5.
And so that gives
me, again, 2/7.
So this calculation basically
illustrates, if this number
has become 2/7, then
the next number is
also going to be 2/7.
And of course this number here
is going to have to be 5/7.
And this one would have to
be again, the same, 5/7.
So the probability that I find
myself at state 1, after a
long time has elapsed, settles
into some steady state value.
So that's an interesting
phenomenon.
We just make this observation.
Now we can also do the
calculation about the
probability, starting
from state 2.
And here, you do the
calculations --
I'm not going to do them.
But after you do them, you find
this probability also
settles to 2/7 and this one
also settles to 5/7.
So these numbers here are the
same as those numbers.
What's the difference
between these?
This is the probability that I
find myself at state 1 given
that I started at 1.
This is the probability that I
find myself at state 1 given
that I started at state 2.
These probabilities are the
same, no matter where I
started from.
So this numerical example sort
of illustrates the idea that
after the chain has run for a
long time, what the state of
the chain is, does not care
about the initial
state of the chain.
So if you start here, you know
that you're going to stay here
for some time, a few
transitions, because this
probability is kind of small.
So the initial state does that's
tell you something.
But in the very long run,
transitions of this kind are
going to happen.
Transitions of that kind
are going to happen.
There's a lot of randomness
that comes in, and that
randomness washes out any
information that could come
from the initial state
of the system.
We describe this situation by
saying that the Markov chain
eventually enters
a steady state.
Where a steady state, what
does it mean it?
Does it mean the state itself
becomes steady and
stops at one place?
No, the state of the chain
keeps jumping forever.
The state of the chain will keep
making transitions, will
keep going back and forth
between 1 and 2.
So the state itself, the
Xn, does not become
steady in any sense.
What becomes steady are
the probabilities
that describe Xn.
That is, after a long time
elapses, the probability that
you find yourself at state 1
becomes a constant 2/7, and
the probability that you
find yourself in
state 2 becomes a constant.
So jumps will keep happening,
but at any given time, if you
ask what's the probability that
right now I am at state
1, the answer is going
to be 2/7.
Incidentally, do the numbers
sort of makes sense?
Why is this number bigger
than that number?
Well, this state is a little
more sticky than that state.
Once you enter here, it's kind
of harder to get out.
So when you enter here, you
spend a lot of time here.
This one is easier to get out,
because the probability is
0.5, so when you enter there,
you tend to get out faster.
So you keep moving from one to
the other, but you tend to
spend more time on that state,
and this is reflected in this
probability being bigger
than that one.
So no matter where you start,
there's 5/7 probability of
being here, 2/7 probability
being there.
So there were some really
nice things that
happened in this example.
The question is, whether things
are always as nice for
general Markov chains.
The two nice things that
happened where the following--
as we keep doing this
calculation, this number
settles to something.
The limit exists.
The other thing that happens
is that this number is the
same as that number, which means
that the initial state
does not matter.
Is this always the case?
Is it always the case that as
n goes to infinity, the
transition probabilities
converge to something?
And if they do converge to
something, is it the case that
the limit is not affected by the
initial state i at which
the chain started?
So mathematically speaking, the
question we are raising is
whether Rij(n) converges
to something.
And whether that something to
which it converges to has only
to do with j.
It's the probability that you
find yourself at state j, and
that probability doesn't care
about the initial state.
So it's the question of whether
the initial state gets
forgotten in the long run.
So the answer is that usually,
or for nice chains, both of
these things will be true.
You get the limit which
does not depend
on the initial state.
But if your chain has some
peculiar or unique structure,
this might not happen.
So let's think first about
the issue of convergence.
So convergence, as n goes to
infinity at a steady value,
really means the following.
If I tell you a lot of time has
passed, then you tell me,
OK, the state of the
probabilities are equal to
that value without having
to consult your clock.
If you don't have convergence,
it means that Rij can keep
going up and down, without
settling to something.
So in order for you to tell me
the value of Rij, you need to
consult your clock to
check if, right now,
it's up or is it down.
So there's some kind of periodic
behavior that you
might get when you do not get
convergence, and this example
here illustrates it.
So what's happened
in this example?
Starting from state 2, next time
you go here, or there,
with probability half.
And then next time, no matter
where you are, you move back
to state 2.
So this chain has some
randomness, but the randomness
is kind of limited type.
You go out, you come in.
So there's a periodic pattern
that gets repeated.
It means that if you start at
state 2 after an even number
of steps, you are certain
to be back at state 2.
So this probability here is 1.
On the other hand, if the number
of transitions is odd,
there's no way that you can
be at your initial state.
If you start here, at even times
you would be here, at
odd times you would
be there or there.
So this probability is 0.
As n goes to infinity, these
probabilities, the n-step
transition probability does
not converge to anything.
It keeps alternating
between 0 and 1.
So convergence fails.
This is the main mechanism by
which convergence can fail if
your chain has a periodic
structure.
And we're going to discuss next
time that, if periodicity
absent, then we don't have an
issue with convergence.
The second question if we have
convergence, whether the
initial state matters or not.
In the previous chain, where you
could keep going back and
forth between states 1 and 2
numerically, one finds that
the initial state
does not matter.
But you can think of situations
where the initial
state does matter.
Look at this chain here.
If you start at state 1, you
stay at state 1 forever.
There's no way to escape.
So this means that R11(n)
is 1 for all n.
If you start at state 3, you
will be moving between stage 3
and 4, but there's no way to
go in that direction, so
there's no way that
you go to state 1.
And for that reason,
R31 is 0 for all n.
OK So this is a case where the
initial state matters.
R11 goes to a limit, as
n goes to infinity,
because it's constant.
It's always 1 so
the limit is 1.
R31 also has a limit.
It's 0 for all times.
So these are the long term
probabilities of finding
yourself at state 1.
But those long-term
probabilities are affected by
where you started.
If you start here, you're sure
that's, in the long term,
you'll be here.
If you start here, you're sure
that, in the long term, you
will not be there.
So the initial state
does matter here.
And this is a situation where
certain states are not
accessible from certain other
states, so it has something to
do with the graph structure
of our Markov chain.
Finally let's answer this
question here, at
least for large n's.
What do you think is going to
happen in the long term if you
start at state 2?
If you start at state 2, you
may stay at state 2 for a
random amount of time, but
eventually this transition
will happen, or that transition
would happen.
Because of the symmetry, you are
as likely to escape from
state 2 in this direction, or in
that direction, so there's
probability 1/2 that, when the
transition happens, the
transition happens in
that direction.
So for large N, you're
certain that the
transition does happen.
And given that the transition
has happened, it has
probability 1/2 that it has
gone that particular way.
So clearly here, you see that
the probability of finding
yourself in a particular state
is very much affected by where
you started from.
So what we want to do next is
to abstract from these two
examples and describe the
general structural properties
that have to do with
periodicity, and that have to
do with what happened here with
certain states, not being
accessible from the others.
We're going to leave periodicity
for next time.
But let's talk about
the second kind of
phenomenon that we have.
So here, what we're going to do
is to classify the states
in a transition diagram
into two types,
recurrent and transient.
So a state is said to
be recurrent if the
following is true.
If you start from the state i,
you can go to some places, but
no matter where you go, there
is a way of coming back.
So what's an example for
the recurrent state?
This one.
Starting from here, you
can go elsewhere.
You can go to state 7.
You can go to state 6.
That's all where
you can go to.
But no matter where you go,
there is a path that can take
you back there.
So no matter where you go, there
is a chance, and there
is a way for returning
where you started.
Those states we call
recurrent.
And by this, 8 is recurrent.
All of these are recurrent.
So this is recurrent,
this is recurrent.
And this state 5 is
also recurrent.
You cannot go anywhere from
5 except to 5 itself.
Wherever you can go, you can
go back to where you start.
So this is recurrent.
If it is not the recurrent, we
say that it is transient.
So what does transient mean?
You need to take this
definition, and reverse it.
Transient means that, starting
from i, there is a place to
which you could go, and from
which you cannot return.
If it's recurrent, anywhere
you go, you
can always come back.
Transient means there are places
where you can go from
which you cannot come back.
So state 1 is recurrent -
because starting from here,
there's a possibility that
you get there, and then
there's no way back.
State 4 is recurrent, starting
from 4, there's somewhere you
can go and--
sorry, transient, correct.
State 4 is transient starting
from here, there are places
where you could go, and from
which you cannot come back.
And in this particular diagram,
all these 4 states
are transients.
Now if the state is transient,
it means that there is a way
to go somewhere where you're
going to get stuck and not to
be able to come.
As long as your state keeps
circulating around here,
eventually one of these
transitions is going to
happen, and once that happens,
then there's no way that you
can come back.
So that transient state will
be visited only a finite
number of times.
You will not be able
to return to it.
And in the long run, you're
certain that you're going to
get out of the transient states,
and get to some class
of recurrent states, and
get stuck forever.
So, let's see, in this diagram,
if I start here,
could I stay in this lump
of states forever?
Well as long as I'm staying in
this type of states, I would
keep visiting states 1 and 2
Each time that I visit state
2, there's going to be positive
probability that I escape.
So in the long run, if I were
to stay here, I would visit
state 2 an infinite number
of times, and I would get
infinite chances to escape.
But if you have infinite chances
to escape, eventually
you will escape.
So you are certain that with
probability 1, starting from
here, you're going to move
either to those states, or to
those states.
So starting from transient
states, you only stay at the
transient states for random
but finite amount of time.
And after that happens,
you end up in a class
of recurrent states.
And when I say class, what they
mean is that, in this
picture, I divide the recurrent
states into 2
classes, or categories.
What's special about them?
These states are recurrent.
But there's no communication
between the 2.
If you start here, you're
stuck here.
If you start here, you
are stuck there.
And this is a case where the
initial state does matter,
because if you start here,
you get stuck here.
You start here, you
get stuck there.
So depending on the initial
state, that's going to affect
the long term behavior
of your chain.
So the guess you can make at
this point is that, for the
initial state to not matter,
we should not have multiple
recurrent classes.
We should have only 1.
But we're going to get back
to this point next time.